So in case an assert function would not be available in your language,
you could easily roll out your own.
I'm coming up with my own assert function which I call "my own assert" takes the condition.
If the condition is false, then we raise an assertion error.
Now, if I invoke say "my own assert" on 2+2=4,
very simple test, we can run this and well, nothing happens because the assertion is met.
However, if we assume the 2+2=5,
we can run this and we get an assertion error that's being raised in here,
and this gives us almost the same functionality as the built-in assertions.
While you can easily roll out your own assertion,
built-in assertions typically do have a couple of advantages.
There is identification--the built-in assertion typically tells you which assertion failed.
There is location that tell you where the assertion failed--that is where in the code.
They are optional--meaning that they can be turned on or off
although turning assertions off is mostly a bad idea, which we will discuss later.
And finally, they're standardized--meaning that
everybody can immediately recognize an assertion as such because they always take the same form.
In the languages C and C++ for instance,
assertions come with a built-in function named "assert" as in Python
which you get by including a special file assert.h,
and then, as in Python, you use assert except that you put the argument in parenthesis,
and again, you pass the condition as an argument to the assert function.
If this assertion failed, you're going to get a message on the console
right before the program exits,
and the message will look something like this--there you go.
And now, you can see that the message actually has everything we wanted in our built-in assertions.
So first, the failing assertion is identified down here as coming directly from the code.
You see the location here--it's in the file foo.c in line 9.
In C and C++, assertions are optional,
you can turn them on and off using a simple argument to the compiler,
and finally, they're standardized if you include assert.h, that's always the form,
and this is what programmers look for and this is what programmers understand.